president biden's approval rating diving
into uncharted territory with his
crumbling agenda at risk the embattled
president standing at an abysmal 39 in
the real clear politics average of polls
here to react fox news contributor joe
concha
joe what is your assessment here is it
crime is it covid the press conference
what's going on
well i think this indelible impression
carly has been established now and this
is very difficult to reverse too many
people in this country believe and this
includes more than a few democrats that
joe biden is simply not capable not
competent in doing this job at this
stage of his life and look
the factors on the ground belay that
right it's the three steps behind
administration uh three steps behind on
inflation you know calling it transitory
it's temporary for months and months in
2021 when obviously that was not the
case three steps behind on crime not
saying a word about it in most of 2021
while cities are reporting record
homicide rates murders being at a
25-year high according to the fbi three
steps behind on the taliban who took
kabul in about the amount of time it
takes to order a pizza and oh wow we
didn't think they would get there this
quickly and that was the beginning of
the end as far as the president's
polling was concerned and obviously
three steps behind on the border where
someone thought it was a great idea to
stop building a wall or to remain in
mexico policy or to invite migrants to
come to the country and the catastrophe
we're seeing there is the result so it's
hard to put the toothpaste back in the
tube as the old saying it's hard to put
humpty dumpty back together as todd and
i know by telling our kids and that's
why you see this approval now below 40
and it's probably only going to get
worse quite frankly todd but joe it goes
beyond that when you look at the
democrat party i mean they have a real
problem on their hands especially when
it comes to rural voters not being in
line with what the biden agenda is
outgoing congressman john cooper from
tennessee basically raises this point
here quote remind me what the strategy
is to change the minds of rural voters
their strategy is blind hope the
democratic party in tennessee is
basically facing extinction so joe why
aren't democrats trying to appeal
to that rural voter but instead focusing
on only that work woke liberal
city ite
i i think todd honestly they thought
they could script this presidency and
when they got to the fall of 2021 they
said okay this is where we're going to
push build back better 3.5 trillion in
new spending on things that have nothing
to do with the things we just talked
about as far as inflation in fact it
would only make it worse as far as crime
as far as the border as far as
afghanistan as far as education so they
were completely tone deaf and then in
2022 when they could do a reset right a
pivot what do they do they talk about
voting rights and how they have to ram
that home because democracy is at peril
and people are sitting at home saying
you are not in touch with what we're
feeling and going through right now and
you seem like perhaps we need to change
power in washington that's probably
going to happen in november when
republicans almost certainly take back
the house and probably take back the
senate and one of the issues facing the
bite administration in a big way is
covid 19. and the head of one of the
nation's largest teachers unions randy
weingarten she was on another network
yesterday she said that in order to end
masking
there essentially needs to be no
transmission in schools um extremely
unrealistic i am sure you have some
serious thoughts on this one
oh boy
zero transmission in schools look covet
is not going away completely it will
become an endemic but it's not going to
become you know the the pandemic part is
is coming to an end it seems but to say
zero transmission is like saying we're
gonna have zero transmission of the flu
schools are overwhelmingly safe and the
fact that terry mcauliffe bought randy
weingarten who you just quoted on stage
as his last speaker before he lost in
virginia it is a losing argument that
almost every parent even those that
would probably vote democratic say wait
a minute zero that is utterly ridiculous
and randy weingarten
is not the messenger here that we should
be trusting in any way shape or form
guys yeah talk about not reading the
room quick correction i refer to him as
john cooper his name is jim cooper john
cooper is a hockey coach and a very good
one at that his name is joe concha you
can't call him anything else joe thank
you thank you so much i thought he's
always got something hey todd if you did
a babysitter by the way i got a guy for
you all right drive up to connecticut he
needs some extra bucks all right thanks
joe 20 an hour oh i come cheap thank you
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now